[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Alford Nevada head basketball
coach since 2019 won a championship with
bob Knight back in
1987 and of course played in the NBA for
a little while former uh Dallas
Mavericks second round pick 1987 Steve
joins us now Steve thanks for joining us
how should we remember bob
Knight yeah that's a hard one Dan you
obviously know him very well as well but
um I'll just always appreciate coach
for his preparation his
discipline um his ability to teach
players to compete every possession no
matter what the drill was um improving
daily uh and then ultimately I I just
think he was the ultimate winner and
those are traits that I think a lot of
our players a lot of teammates we've
been on a lot of text group text and
we've been talking about that that um
not not just all those traits uh apply
to the basketball court I think even
more so his legacy will be um the people
that were able to play for him and Coach
with him those traits have made them
winners off the court and that's
probably what I'm going to remember most
about Coach how difficult was it in the
moment when you're being coach by Bob
Knight to understand now what you've
extracted oh that that's no question I I
think that was the U that was the art of
what kind of player you're going to be
if um obviously a little different
language uh so uh you had to not ever
take things personal uh you had to know
he loved you and loved you deeply uh
there were a lot of times and and he
said it a lot in coaching to so many
players um he'd always say I want you to
be better than you want to be and I
always took that to heart I always I
never wanted to be that I wanted him to
know that um no I wanted to be that good
as well but there were days Dan that
um he definitely wanted me to be better
than I was on certain days and you had
to you had to Cipher everything out and
understand what he was saying and when
you did that uh that's when I felt like
I really grew as a player and as a
person but I wonder when you won that
National Championship how much was joy
and how much was more of just a
relief oh it was Joy uh
you know the relief part I think kind of
gets
over kind of dramatized um I think when
you're in when you're in battle uh he
was the General I mean that's who he was
and that's the that's the Foxhole you
want to be in and we knew that as
players we were the best prepared team
we felt like we were the most
disciplined team uh he will tell you uh
you know I got an autograph picture on
my wall and he talks about when he wrote
the autograph uh how great a player I
was was then he put in parenthesis
offense
so you so you understand you just you
understood your role and you went out
and played that role the best but you I
think it's like anything Dan when you
put everything in it and then you win it
uh and you have success um you have
great joy and appreciation for the
process and the journey ever think about
leaving
Indiana never and I now there were times
that I would call mom and dad and say
hey you're two hours
away come get me uh you know th those
things happen because it it's it's it
wasn't easy it was tough but I think
that's why you know I got better right
you know Dan I was I was chasing the
all-time scoring record in Indiana which
you know when you're an Indiana kid you
grow up and all the incredible players
that played there and now you're in that
the media is talking about you being
this and that and and we're we're right
in a big 10 Chase and we're going to
Northwestern a team that you know we had
hammered and then on to Wisconsin a team
we beat 55 points at home and we beat
Wisconsin in triple overtime but the
Northwestern game was the first trip and
if I just if if I get my average I break
the school record and you can't help but
think about those things growing up in
the state knowing what you're trying to
do uh and I can remember after that game
we barely won the game my teammates play
a lot better than me and Coach just
ripped me uh in the locker room he
ripped me in the media uh and it was not
about scoring uh it was all about my
leadership and I I really at that point
maybe didn't understand it but when we
got back from that road trip I'm like
you know it wasn't about some individual
thing it was about my lack of leadership
and learning how to lead my team through
difficult times and that's what made
coach special he just knew how to do the
things that he knew the buttons to press
uh to make you better Steve Alford
Nevada head basketball coach won a
championship with bob Knight that was
back in 1987 you got a picture behind
you on the wall uh describe that picture
for the audience that's listening on
radio well that's just a picture of
coach and uh I think I think uh Daryl's
in it and Keith I think Keith Smart's in
it as well and just other teammates of
just after winning the championship in
the super doome in New Orleans and uh
you know just being there with coach and
experiencing that with Coach um was a
very very special moment for all of us
when did you have your last conversation
with him I got to see him about a month
ago um not really conversation coach was
not in very good health but I was able
to sit with Pat his son uh for about
three hours in the home and um you know
just tell stories with Pat Pat was in
junior high when I was playing at uh at
Indiana so known Pat Uh and the family
for a very long time obviously going to
coach's Camp since third grade I I grew
up knowing the coach Knight's family
very very well so I was able to do that
but uh um he's at a much better place
and in peace now because it's been a
it's been a tough road here over the
last several months tell the story when
uh you had to walk home from the
airport well and that's the thing Dan
you appreciate about Coach is that uh he
did it the right way
uh Not only was he a highly successful
winning coach but he did it with uh
Integrity of the rules it was always
about respecting the game with him uh he
loved his players he loved his team and
I did a I posed for a calendar um I was
the I was the month of February I was
the love month Dan
umit this is a fundraiser for sorority
on campus this was a fundraiser for a
sorority on campus for handicapped girls
to go to some summer camp and I thought
I was doing the right thing and but the
wrong thing was you're taught at Indiana
you go to compliance you go to the
assistant coaches you make sure you
cover yourself and I didn't do that that
was my mistake and on top of it it was a
Kentucky game and anybody that knows
coach um and the feelings of Kentucky at
the time um would know what I'm talking
about so the irony of me being suspended
for the Kentucky game for a compliance
issue uh dug deep to coach but it it
again speaks volume as a coach he didn't
fight it he didn't try to get
administrators or people from the
outside to fix it uh he's like no you
made a mistake and now you're going to
feel that mistake because it's not just
going to affect you it's going to affect
your team well I Dan dockage was our GA
at the time I'd played with Dan for a
couple years and so I went to Dan I said
Dan I've been suspended but am I
supposed to go on the road trip or not
he said I don't know what to tell you
but I think I'd be on the bus
so I was on the bus and when you when
you exit a bus for a road trip or any
other time coach would always hit you on
the back as you left the bus and we got
our trench coats on it's cold and I'm
one of the last players off the bus and
I see him just hitting everybody I'll
never forget Dan he hits me and then he
grabs the back of my coat and pulls me
back in the bus and says what are you
doing you're at home you're suspended
think about what you did support your
teammates from home find your own way
home so I'm it's 20 minutes from campus
out in the middle of the winter and I
just start walking I see the plane go
through the clouds and I'm walking I get
about a half mile up the road and the
the poor bus driver saw all this the bus
pulls up next to me he opens up and he
just looks at me he goes need a
ride I said yeah it'd be great right now
I'd appreciate a ride I hope the coach
that the bus driver didn't know that you
know coach I think that that was just
something kept between the yeah I'm sure
it was hey my best of the family great
to talk to you thanks for reminiscing
thanks so much D I appreciate you having
me on that's Steve Alford the bat ahead
basketball coach since 2019 and won a
title there at Indiana 1987